[Musique]
une fille dans glee s'est fait tuer par
des gens du lycée en plus que très
compliqué et troisième à la ville et à
14 ans c'est vrai que en fait on avait
en allait à présent c'est une minute de
silence mais toute la journée quoi je
veux dire exactement qui s'était bel qui
s'était disputé avec une petite qu'il
avait tapé je dis pas c'est pas grave je
vais y aller dans ces cas là on va pour
moi c'était juste une altercation c'est
tout et c'est là où je n'irai ils m'ont
dit ça sert à rien elle est morte
il lui aurait donné des coups de pieds
alors qu'elle était au sol dans le dos
et la tête la victime
à ce moment là était encore consciente
elle gémit c'est les yeux ouverts
le jeune homme et la jeune fille aurait
alors attrapé la victime pour la jeter
dans la seine en contrebas du quai c'est
inquiète très haut en béton d'un côté la
victime de l'autre tu as ici employé de
la plateforme net écoute son objectif
porter assistance à cette jeune fille
victime de revenge porn
je pense que tout est à l'excès
malheureusement on a sûrement une
société déstructurée en manque de
repères de la jeunesse mais ce n'est pas
la faute de la jeunesse c'est
certainement nous qui donnons pas ses
repères
le mobile sans doute une futile histoire
de collégiens l'adolescent serait sorti
brièvement avec ali shah avant de se
mettre en couple avec l'autre
adolescente
puis il a diffusé à toute la classe une
photo de la victime en sous-vêtements
piratés sur les réseaux sociaux
ça se développe beaucoup comme vous
l'avez vu quand on regarde les appels
qui sont passés sur la plate forme de
signalement sur sur le harcèlement
scolaire
il ya des mesures qui ont été prises
évidemment il ya des référents anti
harcèlement dans les académies moi je
pense qu'il en faudrait 1 par
établissement scolaire avec l'épidémie
les jeunes se sont rués vers les écrans
et le phénomène s'est amplifié la
plateforme a constaté une augmentation
de 30% de son activité pendant le
confinement il faut apprendre à l'école
1 la gestion des réseaux sociaux on a vu
les les phénomènes de harcèlement mais
il faut aussi apprendre à gérer des
conflits autrement que par la violence
est ce que les verts sont sortis de
l'angélisme sur ces questions mais bien
sûr regardé à lyon renforcement de la
police municipale
une cinquantaine de députés menacé de
mort j'ai vu que vous avez saisi la
justice
est il vrai que ce sont des députés dont
lé nom de famille commence par c est m
c'est exact notre société traverse des
violences subies des menaces qui sont
importantes
les parlementaires comme les français
d'ailleurs je pense qu'il est important
de réagir liste de députés prix de
manière un peu aléatoire dont le nom de
tous bords c'est pas bien sûr de tout
bois et l'ange est immédiatement informé
les présidents de groupe et saisi le
procureur de la république au titre de
l'article 40 du peu de pauses sur
plupart des éleveurs ont manifesté pour
alerter sur les prix de la viande
notamment dans le cantal à aurillac vous
le voyez sur ces images ça s'est passé
après le coup droit un couvre-feu
ils étaient environ 400 à bloquer des
ronds-points dans à peu près tout le
département
aux etats unis le début de la sélection
des jurés qui décideront du sort de
derek sherwin policiers accusés d'humeur
de josh freed en pologne
il existe des zones anti lgbt en clair
des endroits où les lesbiennes les
elle est bisexuelle et transgenre ne
sont pas autorisés ces zones de
discrimination plus précisément sont de
plus en plus nombreuses
ça y est la reine a publié un communiqué
elle dit prendre les accusations de
racisme formulée par megan très au
sérieux et même affirme qu'une enquête
va être menée comme les autres il a
environ 200 ans il fait un mètre de
large et plus de 50 mètres de haut il ne
faut qu'une demi-heure de travail pour
abattre cet arbre mais il a fallu des
mois de recherches pour trouver ceux qui
seront transformés en poutre pour
reconstruire la base de la fameuse
flèche disparu dans l'incendié de notre
dame